[Música]
muito boa noite a todos
ora como é que o papel que cada um de
nós na sociedade como é que nós podemos
melhorar o mundo existem áreas em que
nós sabemos que é muito mais simples nós
temos exemplos do rodrigues da joana
mesmo exemplo josé todas as questões
estão ligadas à saúde nós sabemos que
são muito importantes e têm um impacto
muito grande na questão que se coloca é
como é que eu posso em qualquer uma das
áreas de impacto real sociedad e vou
falar um bocadinho é sobre o evento no
qual evitou na primeira pessoa que tem a
ver com comunicações tecnologia e
comunicações reduz de comunicação como é
que nós podemos revolucionar as redes de
comunicação
nós pensamos no nosso telemóvel hoje em
dia o que nós conseguimos fazer também
tornamos ainda procuramos criar com que
tem menos do que o normal porque tem
toda a questão das mensagens
toda a questão de proteínas que fazemos
com nossos amigos ouvimos rádio vemos
televisão mas podemos também controlar o
alarme da casa podemos controlar as
luzes e até podemos no futuro não muito
longínquo é algo que poderia fazer já
muito rapidamente
eu posso subir e controlar qual o que eu
tenho do frigorífico que não sabe fazer
e quem sabe comprar de forma automática
ou seja eu consigo neste momento um
controlar muita coisa com sim ter
aplicações e é bastante inovadoras e
porque por um lado porque estou sempre
ligava mas por outro lado porque eu
tenho informação da informação do tudo
eu quero em função do tudo e todos num
determinado local e e cinco viúvas
um casal pode ser uma cidade pode ser
uma determinada zona em que temos tudo
interligado temos as pessoas
temos os carros temos sensores temos
marcos bicicletas conseguimos ter
informação é de tudo em qualquer lugar
e que a questão é como é que nós podemos
fazer quando é que nós podemos
interligar tudo e todos num determinado
local existem imensas tecnologias da
comunicação com os sem fios
algumas longo alcance outras do curto
alcance
algumas em que nós conseguimos por
exemplo virtual visão em tempo real no
registro quer que estejamos enviar muito
muito tráfego e muitas vezes podem ser
caras tecnologias podem não ser não ser
um é o mais relevante em outras
situações nós temos tecnologia que não
conseguia tanta informação
ou seja nós precisamos o que seria ideal
o que seria ideal é que eu tivesse em
qualquer lugar
aquilo que eu tenho aqui tem um ponto de
acesso móvel pra poder aceder à internet
isto seria o ideal não só pra mim mas
para tudo em qualquer local incluindo um
qualquer sensor que eu tenho na cinda
ato que possa indicar por exemplo se
está calor se está frio está muito por
essa cidade está ou não está com vida
mas isso é impossível é impossível ter
um ponto de acesso sempre sempre em
todos os locais
ora há uns tempos a vários anos atrás eu
comecei a trabalhar numa área tem a ver
com comunicações entre veículos reduz
veículos o que é isso
dois veículos o objetivo era que o cara
todos os cargos em comunicação e
comunicação entre 11 e também por deus
legal da internet mas porque nós
queríamos fazer algo desse gênero
ora por um lado se a uma travagem busca
eu posso querer revisar o carro está
atrás de mim e aviso do forma automática
e eu sabe que é uma travagem com o
trabalho também é porque primeiro
acidente existe um veículo de emergência
uma ambulância e eu posso ter essa
informação e saber o que preciso fazer
a partir daí eu posso por exemplo um
porto no mar chegou o navio com touros é
preciso caminho conjunto caminhões
buscar os vários contentores para
colocar nos bairros locais tudo isso tem
que estar muito bem
tornando o que significa que eu fiz
saber onde estão os contentores onde
estão os caminhões de poder coordenar
todo este processo ou mesmo por exemplo
eu sei onde é que existe mais tráfego -
tráfego na cidade ea partir daí poder
dar informações aos vários condutores
por onde é que os devem seguir para que
para melhorar o tráfego ou seja para
colocar os vários com torres vários
carros nas várias zonas da cidade para
que não haja congestionamento estava
entre santa isso é muito interessante
nem tanto para as aplicações que
permitiria mas porque sendo
originariamente docente e investigadora
a nível científico nós temos que criar
uma rede em movimento em uma via de
movimento significa que todos têm que
estar em comunicação entre os 19 foto
carros e oscar estão sempre em movimento
ea sociedade podem ser votos também em
coisas estão em movimento nós temos que
estar arrastão será feito para garantir
que ela continua e que funciona e isso
eram é os grandes objetivos da
investigação ou seja ter aqui uma
síndica bastante interessante realizar
agora a questão que se coloca
então se eu consigo colocar os veículos
em comunicação o que acontece por acaso
um destes cargos for o tal ponto acesso
wifi que eu tenha falado anteriormente
como disse não possuir um processo em
todos os locais nos carros andam pela
cidade usando pelas várias ruas eles
conseguem enquanto se movimentam andar
por todo lado e 11 deste carro e se um
conjunto de sindicatos foi um ponto de
acesso wifi o que significa que aquela
internet que eu tenho em casa e que
ganhe aqui eu posso vala para estradas e
algumas praças estradas enquanto eu
estou num carro quando estou próximo de
um carro eu possa aceder à internet sem
qualquer problema
mas muito mais do que isso é que se
tiver sensor todos espalhados pela
para uma cidade por um determinado
espaço enquanto eu me movimento no meu
carro eu posso vai servir de ponto de
acesso móvel por estes hoje e essa é a
idéia principal é conseguir construir
uma rede de comunicação dos veículos num
determinado espaço para poder agora sim
então ligar tudo e todos e podemos ter
carros podendo ter barcos podemos ter
bicicleta os motociclos mesmo ter as
próprias pessoas que vencer todas elas
pontos de acesso móvel à internet em
movimento
eu vou mostrar um vídeo que mostra como
é que isto poderá funcionar para o que
nós podemos ver aqui cada um dos cargos
é um ponto de acesso móvel
ou seja eu consegue dar acesso à
internet a quem quer que esteja por
perto
além disso cada carro e os outros carros
aqui podemos ter um exemplo dos barcos
também o que eu estou fazendo eu estou
formar uma rede completa não treinando
espaço que ocupamos uma malha e
guerreiro que permita dar acesso à
internet a tudo o que estiver próximo
desta rede e este é o objetivo principal
é por um lado cada pessoa tem vocês a
internet onde quer que esteja
por outro lado eu consigo ligar tudo e
todos em qualquer lugar e aquilo que nós
chamamos a internet em movimento e como
é importante perceber se estas
publicações realmente funcionava aqui
nós fizemos foi colocar na prática seja
vamos colocar os veículos e comunicar
numa cidade que escolhemos a cidade do
porto para fazer porque é uma cidade
suficientemente grande com uma grande
como a escala é incentivada e vamos
instalar os nossos objetivos comunicação
em cada um dos veículos
escolhemos várias frotas uma delas tem a
ver com a psp os autocarros é na cidade
do porto o que nos permite que nos
permitem fazer com isto
neste momento há mais agentes públicos
em comunicação na cidade que eles fazem
ora por um lado dão acesso à internet
as pessoas que estão próximas voltando a
tocar a única coisa que eu tenho que
fazer a carne o telemóvel e jogar no
computador do meu pai perto e ricardo
barreto se encontrando a tocar não
preciso fazer mais nada
a partir daí eu posso dizer toda a
viagem aceder à internet com vídeos
a virtualização também sem qualquer
problema porque porque os carros fazem
tudo entre felson e outros que fazem com
que eu esteja sempre ligado à internet
sem haver qualquer mudança sem eu sentir
que os carros andam realmente movimento
mas não fazemos só isso
ao mesmo tempo nós temos um conjunto de
sensores questão é da cidade e que nós
fazemos em sochi
os sensores são da temperatura da
poluição e os vão sempre que do teto o
que existe com o carro ao seu alcance e
porque ostentam pela reeducar eu enviam
informação contém por esta informação
vai através dos carros até até o ponto
da infraestrutura servidor nós possamos
agregar à informação e para os aula ea
partir daí fazer aplicações
interessantes com ela posso dar uma um
exemplo concreto em funcionamento que
tem a ver com uma melhoria das rotas que
são realizadas pelos caminhões da coleta
de resíduos ou seja neste momento eu não
tenho uma rota normal todos os dias a
rota deus tem a ver com qual é que o
limita deduzidos que cada contentor tem
porquê porque cada contentor de um
sensor este sensor prometemos
identificar em que o limite é incrível é
que ela se encontra a informação e
acolhida quando chegou ao servidor e
quando ultrapasso terminado o vovô nós
contactamos nós a rede
este servidor contactar directamente o
caminho esteja mais próxima
claro que aqui nós conseguimos poupar
bastante combustível em tempo e também a
poluição porque os carros vão andar na
estrada também causa muita poluição
e precisamos ficar roxo
nós vamos sempre ter carros não nós
apenas precisamos ter a oxi mova num
determinado espaço podem ser os carros
podem ser motociclos podem ser as
bicicletas podem ser barcos podem ter
esse dom e hoje em dia fala-se muito das
gestões agricultura em que nós queremos
o podia ter sensores nas plantas que têm
sensores também nos terrenos e não é
fácil a chegar hoje temos drogas podem
lá chegar e que podem recolher toda a
informação que é necessária podendo até
se nós nos a nós próprios com os nossos
telemóveis nós podemos recolher
informação e pretendem ter acesso à
internet em qualquer um destes momentos
e como é que nós poderíamos colocar isto
em prática este é um exemplo
eu tenho aqui em vários momentos em
movimento podem ser os autocarros podem
ser os tons que todo em buscar
informação aos sensores e ao mesmo tempo
da informação as pessoas nesta pessoa
que está a ver um vídeo tem pessoas
dentro do autocarro também ea partir daí
poder usar qualquer tipo de tecnologias
para enviar tudo essa informação e dá
poder aceder à internet e que nós
podemos fazer
vai existir uma novidade de coisa mas a
partir daqui nós podemos ter um conjunto
de aplicações novas em que os ventos não
são 200 porque nós temos mais de 200 mas
em 200 porque nós conseguimos dados mais
informação porque nós porque elas
conseguem trabalhar com mais informação
deixamos de dar alguns exemplos por
exemplo se eu saio onde estão sempre em
qualquer local
todos os veículos numa determinada zona
euro é conseguir tráfico
eu também consigo disso verificar um de
que há problemas em identificar os
problemas e partilhem graus ou seja
agora a pouco vou mandar estes contornos
para cada um destes locais para poder
minimizar esse problema ou poder posso
entre os carros inatel saber logo com as
suas várias partes quais são as áreas
onde não posso ensinar e assim que o
tecido é que eu sou assim ano eu tenho
alguma aplicação
ps que me leva diretamente é tem aqui um
local até ao local onde eu posso
estacionar ou eu estou a correr e eu
gosto de correr em zonas pouco poluída
sou só eu posso ter automaticamente com
as duas melhores recursos de correr e
além disso eu posso ter um conjunto
sensor no meu corpo que permitem por um
lado identificar se há problemas e poder
logo chamar um médico se for necessário
avisar o médico
por outro lado apostar em contante
constante interação com o personal
trainer sabe exatamente o que eu estou
fazendo o que ele vai fazer
a partir daí ou tenha controlar as luzes
do forma automática e somente um gênio
também no local a nível do turismo
poderá aplicar sanções aos turistas
poderão entregar logo informação do que
aquilo caos podem fazer integração com o
transporte ser logo uma coordenação com
os vários gritos dos vários locais onde
hoje vão visitar nível da agricultura
poder sensibilizar as plantas poderá
sensibilizar os treinos poder saber
quando é que elas precisam da água
realmente o que eu estou a precisar
daquele momento a questão de gestão do
sinduscon escola ainda há pouco duas a
questão da saúde seja um acidente logo
na ambulância existe um contato direto
como meta inclusive com possível poder
ter um vídeo que envia tudo a informação
que não sabia sobre a pessoa e até nos
carros autônomos que é o que hoje em dia
está a investigar e que as comunicações
podem ter um ponto muito relevante ou
seja se eu quero ter um carro sem
condutor o que eu preciso de saber como
o carro se saber o nexus one é que estão
todos os outros
quando é que os dirigem cola que a
sociedade toda a emoção que eu posso
sisters começaram por sensores só um
carro que travar bruscamente eu preciso
ter logo essa informação seja tem que
haver logo essa comunicação eu fiz saber
se há curvas se há problemas nas
estradas e apurados antes sensores ao
longo da estrada que comunicam essa
informação precisa interagir com os mafa
se interagir com os sinais de trânsito e
por isso haver uma interligação também
entre luz e claro sobre a queda
chicletes motociclos para que não haja
sedentos e um de criar aumente em 2 hoje
consigo fazer isto basta que elas têm um
telemóvel ou tem algum sensor que os
possa tentar ea partir daqui que eu
poderei ter toda a coordenação autônoma
sem qualquer intervenção da pessoa
voltando à questão inicial qual é o
nosso papel para que o meu papel com o
papel que cada um de nós
ora se fazemos algo e cremos que só faça
a diferença na vida das pessoas
não temos muitas opções seja uma das
opções já que vamos colocá lo em prática
neste caso vamos colocar um produto e
vamos local em todo mundo
essa tecnologia que eu posso falar é que
algo está em portugal desde a estréia
nos estados unidos em cingapura e
objetivo em si mesmo é que nós não
tenhamos não fôssemos só para nós nós
possamos expandir para que possamos
mostrar pra todo mundo que se pode fazer
e pretendem poder sentir realmente mudar
a vida das pessoas e como diz qualquer
área possa ser a área das redes de
comunicações da maré muito ativa muito
dinâmica e que não quer salvar em como é
que vai ser o futuro mas de uma coisa
nós sabemos que qualquer que seja o
futuro todas estas desenvolvimento que
nós estamos a fazer aqui podem ter
impacto muito grande no futuro e minha
questão pra vocês é vejam qual é o vosso
papel em que vocês podem realmente fazer
a diferença em qualquer área pode trazer
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]